[Music]
hello and welcome to chinese whispers
with me cindy yoo every episode i'll be
talking to journalists experts and
long-time china watchers about the
latest in chinese politics society and
more there will be a smattering of
history to catch you up on the
background knowledge and some context
how do the chinese see these issues
it's clear now that vladimir putin's
army is not as competent or as effective
as he was hoping for and while that's
celebrated in much of the world there
are those in china specifically
beijing's military leaders who are going
to be concerned about what they're
seeing on the ground not least because
of china's people's liberation army has
been so heavily influenced whether in
terms of strategy or equipment by the
russian army and that is a relationship
that goes back all the way to the soviet
union days
so could the people's liberation army
which hasn't been in active combat since
1979 in vietnam similarly flounder if a
war were to happen to discuss i'm joined
by timothy r heath who's a senior
researcher at the american think tank
the rand corporation and professor lisa
albing who is a military historian who
used to serve in a people's liberation
army himself
now tim and subbing welcome to chinese
whispers to start with i wonder if we
can give an overview of the current
weaknesses and strengths of the pla tim
can we talk about his size because am i
right in thinking that it's the world's
largest army what are the implications
of that in terms of how effective it is
well the pla is the world's largest
military if you count by
sheer number of personnel
however
that metric by itself does not tell us a
lot there are a lot of countries with
huge militaries like north korea
which has a disproportionately large
military given its small size as a
country
but as we know north korea is not
especially modern or powerful as a as a
military force what makes the pla
distinctive is not just the size but how
modern uh it has become over the past
few decades it has made leaps and bounds
so to speak in terms of improving the
quality of weapons and equipment and in
some of the key organizational reforms
that are
really quite impressive
so maybe you can just give us an
overview of those reforms that have come
i mean am i writing thinking that a lot
of them have come under xi jinping as
well
yes i agree with tim c the
general description of the people's
liberation army especially in the the
recent years
uh not just uh maintain
the number in one and half million
uh active
troops
but also this improvement of the uh
quality
like uh teams mentioned modernization or
education
before the reform
most of the
new recruits from the rural areas
now is about the 40 percent
of the proa soldiers from the urban
areas was with some kind of education
at least with a high school of graduates
so
for the office core
now is about 60 percent of the pra
officers with a college degree
uh much better than higher than
a pre-reform period
so give me reform an opening yeah
and quality there's a
we face a different army
and can we talk a little bit about the
equipment and the technology of it as
well timothy i mean
how does it fare compared to other major
armies or say the american one in terms
of what weapons it has um what uh boats
and ships here here's my technical
knowledge coming out here
how far does that extend
well i think
the improvements in the hardware are
probably one of the strengths of the pla
and we'll get to the weaknesses
but
in terms of missiles in particular the
pla is actually quite advanced they have
some of the world's most advanced
ballistic missiles that are very
accurate and can go very long ranges
they pose a real threat to the us navy
for example and its
desire to operate close to china
china has also improved the quality of
its warships the surface ships in
particular destroyers have very good
surface-to-air missile capabilities and
improved
sensors and overall
reduced signatures which makes them a
little bit harder to detect
the chinese air force has improved a lot
of its aircraft
they have fourth generation aircraft um
they're still
have weaknesses in producing quality
engines and depend on russian engines in
particular but overall the combat
capability of the latest chinese
aircraft is comparable
if not quite at the level of the us they
are getting closer to the quality of u.s
aircraft ground troops have generally
lagged
in modernization efforts
but compared to a lot of china's
neighbors the pla ground forces are more
than a match
and shelving what about
those weaknesses then where do you think
they lie
well they
as a team she mentioned here
there is a gap
between the
technology
and the
operation
some of those the high-tech weapons
haven't been tested or used before
they showed you know during their parade
and celebration and they're available
but
how it works you know really
during the
real comeback situation has been tested
yet
so there's a gap between the technology
and the operation
in terms of the
weapon system
and also
there is a
issue about the combat effectiveness
even though we talked about the number
the year of
you know but uh
pla
hasn't fought a war
in several decades you know the last
large-scale war we know
was the war between
china and vietnam in 1980s
about 40 years ago
so
without recent experience
the current generation of the pra
officer and the troops
still face a serious uh
issue about their combat effectiveness
that's why the pra
had
conducted a frequent
exercises try to improve
their comeback effectiveness but there's
no proof
about how they're going to be
during the real battle
i think it's helpful to look at the
russian experience in ukraine
um because the chinese military imitates
the russian military in many ways and
there are a lot of similarities what we
see in the russian cases uh a military
that did a lot of training did a lot of
exercises has advanced weapon systems
but it is the problems of corruption
problems of uh
of uh authoritarian control that that
makes officers and troops hide
problems and and uh be afraid to tell
what's what the real situation is these
are the kind of issues that plague the
russian combat performance and i think
there's a real reason to suspect that if
the chinese went to combat as well their
own problems with corruption and lack of
preparation lack of honesty in the ranks
would reveal themselves pretty quickly
in the performance on the battlefield
well that's really interesting point
maker timothy about corruption uh
shopping because
the pla has the second largest military
budget uh in in the world i mean
obviously it's still only a third
roughly what the american one is but
it's still pretty big do you think that
money is well used at the moment
because president xi did go on
anti-corruption drive you know when he
first came to power so has that had
effect
yes yeah the
military budget uh has increased
annually
uh
this year again up to a seven percent
from last year
but xi jinping and his uh
military leaders justify the increase
believe they're still you know below
uh two percent of the total gdp
and much less than other countries like
united states
and several others
so
but
proa does need a big budget to
upgrade their weapon system
because their
technology
depended on
foreign purchase
and
importation so they need a cash flow to
buy
the weapons like from russia
the su-35
uh fighters
so china had been the largest
buyer of russian
airplanes in the past decade
so
there's a
issues between
the military and the administration
about the
budget
so
to ensure the military
loyalty
and the support
so she continued to increase the budget
in the recent years
let's talk about russia then because
that's already come up a couple of times
so far tim i think it's fair to say that
russian the russian troops haven't
performed as well in ukraine as
many had feared and they had hoped so do
you think that the people's liberation
army will be watching from within china
to see if what their mistakes are and
how that what that means for the pla
itself
oh absolutely
russia is a close partner of china
and a lot of the pla's organization
equipment doctrine
all a lot of that is inspired by the
russian military and the russian
experience
and even today a lot of the practices of
the pla
are similar to how the russian military
practices or operates for example
there's there's a reliance in russia and
china on conscription
for a sizable portion of the enlisted
force
and the chinese military has pervasive
problems of corruption especially in its
logistic systems just like the russian
military does
there is also a strong political
uh flavor to the pla obviously as a
political army but you know the russian
military similarly is a very politicized
military with a strong emphasis on
obedience to
you know putin president putin so a lot
of the issues that we're seeing in the
russian military are going to be of high
concern to the pla because there's a
very good chance the chinese military
could have some of the similar issues
when you say corruption is that still an
issue now um just going back to you know
this thought that presidency did have an
anti-corruption drive did that not
affect the army
well it definitely affected the army and
it took out a lot of officers but the
corruption is certainly a pervasive
issue
and the corruption is mainly
concentrated in two parts of the
military the logistics system where
there's a lot of money changing hands
and and supplies that are easily lost
track of
uh that's historically where a lot of
the corruption has affected pla by the
way it's also where a lot of the
corruption has hit the russian military
and shown to be a serious problem and
then the other part of the pla that
suffers corruption issues is the
political department the department
responsible for promotions and the issue
what you have there is that people will
pay to be promoted
and to move up and that that has been a
problem it continues to be a problem and
it affects the ability of the chinese
leadership to have confidence in the pla
because they just don't know
who in command is actually deserving and
competent enough to carry out
the military duties and who is not
well the classic chinese guanxi
relationship building um network
um and so being some people have said
and i mean i can see the merit in this
argument which is that watching how the
russian army has fared in ukraine makes
china think twice about any military
action against taiwan do you think that
similar there's a fair argument from a
military standpoint could the chinese
army similarly flounder because of its
influence by the russian side in a
military engagement
at a strategic level no
but at the operational level yes
at a strategic level china considered
taiwan's different
uh from the ukraine
and
china would
play a different war game
if
invasion took place
but as a tim she mentioned here china
chinese military has been watching the
war closely so sure they learning from
russians lessons and they would make
a change
adjustment in their
operation to deal with the
battleground situation like you know
supply line like uh
people's support you know make sure that
they're good with people's work they not
uh engaging a hostile
territory they need a friendly support
from local level so they're learning and
they
learn from the russian army
and tim you mentioned just now that the
people's liberation army is a political
army let's talk about that because it's
not your usual army it's not a national
institution because it's one that
technically answers to the chinese
communist party can you talk about that
structure a little
certainly so the
pla is technically a party army that is
it is the armed wing of the chinese
communist party and therefore it is not
answerable to the nation of china it's
answerable to the communist party and
its ultimate goal is to protect the
communist party so what that means is
that a lot of the command structure and
the political controls in the military
is designed to ensure that the parties
authorities unquestioned and is not
necessarily designed to ensure maximum
military effectiveness there are party
committees for example that oversee
decision making at at almost all levels
of the military and and they supervise
the commander
there are political commissars who whose
job is partly to keep an eye on the
leadership and check their political
reliability and there's an ex extensive
emphasis on political indoctrination and
political training in the pla uh that
you don't find in in non-party
militaries and a lot of these political
controls erode or
start to
cause friction in the pla's efforts to
become a highly efficient lethal combat
machine because they have to spend a lot
of resources and energy
ensuring compliance with all these
political directives political controls
and political oversight
and am i right in thinking that because
of this it's also subject to political
turmoil for example during the cultural
revolution it also was subject to purges
well historically that has been a huge
issue with uh party armies is they can
be prone to factional infighting the
latest example we saw in china was
uh boshilai there were reports
that parts of the pla had been
approached by boshila and his cronies
and there were efforts to solicit
support for military uh aid
if boshilai decided to to take really
risky actions towards his central
leadership it never came to that but the
chinese after boshilai's downfall did
the chinese authorities report they did
carry out some investigations to uh
figure out which parts of the pla may
have been tempted to support this
factional leader
yeah and that's not the first time the
pla has been used for political purposes
during the cultural revolution though it
had its fair share of purges and
fractures it was also what mao relied on
to regain control of the red guards so
ben can you tell us about what the
cultural revolution did for the pla's
power
so during the cultural revolution
uh pra moved into the political center
and uh
in return as the teams mentioned here
actually party
uh dependent army or in other words
the pla saved
the chinese communist party
during the cultural revolution
but it did again you know in terms of
square in 1989 again the army
saved the party
so during the political crisis
a party always turned to the military
and depended on the military
so they want to make sure
this army is served party's interest
but you've also written about how the
pla or some people in it refused to
carry out the orders for example during
the tiaman protest is that right
yes
since
many of the recruitment
took place in the
same area
so many of the soldiers knew each other
before they joined the army
so they tried to
be a good soldier
try to join the party during their
service
and uh
get a promotion
prepared for their their future
but of course that's they just you know
their
hope and their wish but when the reality
took place you know camden square
when they have to open the fire to the
students and the citizens
uh
many soldiers change their mind
so
according to official statistics there
about the 1400 soldiers
dropped the weapon
and
left the site
or run away
about the 211 officers
refused i mean this at operational level
commanders on the front
211 officers refused to carry the order
there's many more you know at the higher
level but at operational level those uh
food soldier and the field officers
uh
changed their mind during the
tenement square
event
that's amazing because i think we've
seen a low level to be sure a low level
of similar phenomenon happening in the
russian army over the last couple of
months tim do you think something
similar
might happen with pla soldiers if china
conducted um and i'm sorry to make dual
equivalence here again i'll do a
comparison here to taiwan or just
anywhere else um because i am aware that
it's a bit of a overdone comparison
but do you think that um
you know soldiers might say we don't
want to fight people that look like us
speak like us
in terms of the pla
yes yeah that happened
during the korean war
and during china's work with vietnam
twenty thousand chinese soldiers were
captured during the korean war
after the war seventy percent of the
chinese pows
didn't want to go back to china and they
went to taiwan
so that's really embarrassing for the
chinese government
in the cold war
so they developed this suicide pill
issue to each soldiers
before the battle
and the
chinese army is still
one of the few army in today's world
to issue the suicide appeal to the
soldiers
that's never heard in the american
military and not even in the russian
troops
if you you can surrender you know you
can
but not for the chinese they call it the
glory appeal
okay give you a something like a tylenol
you know small pill
each soldier received one and uh when
you lost
ability to fight
you need to take the pill
instead of being captured
so that was a pretty uh serious
uh issue during the war with vietnam in
1979
1985
still large number of chinese troops
including
female soldiers captured by the
vietnamese troops
wow and um and that's to stop them from
defecting if they were captured yes
right i see and tim did you want to come
back on that
yeah i thought i'd make a offer a few
points about the pla's role in
suppressing domestic opposition to the
party
and then uh any thoughts and some
thoughts about the russia experience in
the ukraine what it might mean for
taiwan
so one point i'd make about tiananmen
square is that the
experience of the pla was such a shock
for the military and for the political
party the ccp chinese communist party
that a decade later
the chinese government
took the pla out of the job of
suppressing domestic
dissent and gave them an explicit set of
orders to just focus on external threats
they instead created a new service the
people's armed police the pap
and they created it by carving out large
chunks of the army and turned them into
this paramilitary service whose job was
to
crush domestic
dissent or opposition and communist rule
so
i think that creation of the pap and the
reorientation the pla shows
just how damaging that tiananmen square
experience was to the the morale of the
pla to the people's confidence and trust
in the military and in the communist
party uh and and ever since then
uh you know evidence suggests that
people serving the pla are definitely
much more comfortable
much more proud to be focused on
external threats and do not want to be
put back in the job of
crushing domestic opposition even though
that is ultimately one of their most
basic missions that is always available
if the pap and other law enforcement
fails to do their job
um the the point about russia i'd make
is that
i think there is an important difference
between the russian experience and any
potential chinese invasion of taiwan
first
the russian invasion was carried out on
some
false pretenses at least for a lot of
russian conscripts they didn't
understand
uh the mission and they were deceived uh
with propaganda about what would happen
and what they're trying to do and that
that was a huge issue for a lot of the
troops who were shocked when they find
out to find out that uh this was not in
you know some kind of mission where you
just walk into ukraine and the people
welcome you and there's no fighting
they're misled and and that's a reason
why a lot of russian soldiers threw down
their arms and have fled and surrendered
or defected
in the chinese case there has been
extensive propaganda to try to teach the
chinese people and the pla that they had
this you know sacred mission to liberate
taiwan
that said
you know i do think i i have my own
suspicions that if a war broke out
there is a possibility that chinese
troops could be shocked to find when
they cross the strait
um that they are killing these folks who
look a lot like them who don't want to
be a part of china who are fighting hard
to defend their own freedom
and um you know some of the similar
issues of doubt and low morale and
questioning of the cause that the
russians are experiencing ukraine i
could easily see that playing out in
large parts of the pla during a bloody
murderous attack on on taiwan that
involved the slaughter of large numbers
of civilians
and tim i wondered from you um could you
talk a little bit about the strategic
thinking
that the pla might have towards war i.e
is there a war with chinese
characteristics um when to wage war
theory with chinese characteristics for
example you yourself have written about
two faces of strategy uh pre and
postmail
well
there is the operational doctrine of how
do you fight if directed by the
leadership
and the chinese definitely have a well
articulated doctrine of uh what they
call informative war
um chinchiwa
and that's the idea that you fight a war
with digital technologies that allow all
fighters you know aircraft ships tanks
in a network
that can communicate with each other
share data target uh different platforms
and and pass on that targeting
data and that allows a
joint force an integrated joint force to
fight as a cohesive whole rather than
everybody fighting on their own so
there's a well articulated doctrine on
that
in terms of when
or why the pla may fight that's a
political decision that is ultimately
only known to the leadership of china
my own assessment is that the chinese
leadership currently
do not have an interest or desire to
provoke a war
with any of their neighbors
including taiwan
and that they recognize that the they
have other priorities right now in
particular the economy trying to get
that to
you know
sustain them sustainable the growth and
overcome some of the severe imbalances
managing relations with with the us and
with uh china's neighbors um and and
just managing the domestic political
situation xi jinping is is constantly
facing challenges by his own fellow
elites and
and the situation in china is hardly
what you could say
completely stable so they've got serious
challenges there as well so given that
all those economic and political and
international challenges
it's hard to see a
reason for the chinese to want to
provoke a war and there's no evidence
that i can see that the chinese
leadership have an interest and do that
anytime soon
as well as covet of course and the
challenge of covet is uh the country's
in lifetime
they've got some real challenges on the
leadership's hands right now
some people might say that this is the
ideal time to wage a war because it
distracts from the domestic problems
what do you think about that argument
i don't buy that argument at all i i
don't see how war improves the situation
at all it makes it frankly all worse
um the biggest problem with starting war
is that you
like all wars you can't and the russians
are experiencing this you can't end the
war when you want to because the other
side gets a vote
so the chinese could start a war that
ends up causing the economy to crash in
china and maybe uh people get so angry
and fed up with their uh what's
happening to their lives they start
protesting larger numbers the situation
could easily spiral out of control and
um you know it seems like there's no way
a war would help improve china's
situation today in all likely ways it
would just make it far far worse
and shopping you know uh we're speaking
about all of this quite academically but
you yourself have served in the people's
liberation army can you talk a little
bit about why you join and i think for
audience members you know it's
interesting to know that even your name
xiao is little soldier so your parents
had had this in mind for you
well that that
means a lot since my parents served
and then uh
they
hope you know i will follow the family
tradition
so that's they give me the name little
soldier
uh back then was a pretty popular you
know it's a lot of people use a
bean
in part of their name and many chinese
serve
during my service you know in the early
70s
the total uh poas numbered about
6 million
that's a large army six million
and again that's the just during the
cultural revolutions no
uh education no college to go
no
[Music]
employed opportunity
so join army could you know
provide a better future
so
uh
many uh youth like me after high school
like to
join army to avoid manual labors and
farm works
so that was a popular
decision back then in the early 1970s
and during the service you know easy for
uh the soldiers to join the
ccp chinese communist party after you
became a party member that's your job
security
easier to find a girlfriend after your
service and
you can get a promotion and pay raise
which is a political ticket
so but uh all of a sudden the thing
changed you know because i served in
along the russian border
so we were told the russians are coming
and there was a border crisis
during that time
so we became very nervous because of the
wars coming upon us we were not well
trained not well equipped
so we belong to the
district
uh military command not belong to the
field army command
considered as the second class like
national guard the local defense force
not well equipped
but we are lucky the war didn't broke
out
and
after
uh second year
i left military and get a better job you
know i joined army before i was a farmer
and then after surveys i became a oil
field worker in darting
petroleum oil fuel
so that's my brief service during the
early 70s
and as you say um the pla has changed
quite a lot over the decades because now
it's having
close links to cutting-edge scientists
within china and universities and it's
even had a role in the vaccine
development with cancino
and chenwei this epidemiologist who's at
the academy of medical military sciences
who's also reportedly a pla major
general so could you talk a little bit
about that
push to have i guess more brains in the
in the operation is that a
strategic move to have more um highly
educated people involved
yeah that's also happened believe it or
not during the cultural revolution
when mao zedong shut down all the
schools and research institute
when all the intellectuals educated
became the target of the revolution
somehow the military
stepped in including
and they created military research
institute to
attract or recruit
those professors
researchers and the scientists to
serving the military
so from then on after 70s and 80s pra
developed intellectual power
they built their own research lab in
their military institutes and
academics
and began to design
and manufacture their own worship
submarine
and
airplanes
so thereafter
in the
80s and 90s during the
reforming movement
some of the their second turning point
military research tried to leave the
proa do you know why
but they don't pay that much you know
other people in a society
get better income
so don't try to save the army
like you said corruption
actually he started allowing the
military to run business
commercialization of the poa to keep the
intellectuals
in the military by
compensate them with their own
benefits
second jobs
right so so
even you know jungle means terminated
the commercialization
and
but somehow
he trade off
with the military i give you pay risk
i increase your budget
so you don't have to get the in uh you
know under the table through the illegal
channel so here is what he wants
so with johnson means uh
pay back
what the done what
military belief don't own the military
now jian say i pay you back and then so
military keep
the
intellectuals so until today
they had pretty
strong program
in terms of
aerospace technology
and other research area including the
nuclear
research and the development
so
they may have the
best
people and resources
in the military
it's not in the private sector like here
in the great britain and america but the
poa
maintain their leading role
in international research
that's fascinating tim am i writing
thinking that there's quite a live
debate going on stateside at the moment
about chinese scientists
working or coming from
institutions where media reports say
that they are linked to the pla
i'm not sure what those links
necessarily are in these reports but in
america it does seem like there is quite
a
suspicion at the moment about
cutting-edge scientists possibly
actually just working for the people's
liberation army how legitimate do you
think those concerns are
well i
i do think it is accurate to say that
the
chinese military and the chinese
government
are interested and actively seeking to
acquire technology from western
countries even though i agree with xiao
being that the pla has dramatically
improved
the quality of its personnel in terms of
education and technical expertise
by the own estimates of the pla the
chinese are lagging behind the west
badly
a lot of their most advanced weapon
systems are frankly rip-offs of russian
designs the chinese innovations are
mostly refinements and slight
improvements to either u.s or russian
designs and systems
and therefore
to get the most advanced technologies
the chinese
have struggled to be the innovators and
have instead turned to
foreign acquisition through
espionage if necessary
now that said
although i think there's plenty of
evidence that the chinese government and
the chinese military are actively
seeking
uh through espionage to acquire western
technology
you know it is a fair debate
in western democratic societies about
how much you want to uh characterize the
work of ethnic chinese citizens
as acts of espionage um there's a whole
debate on that that you know it's kind
of a sideshow to what we're talking
about here and and there are legitimate
questions of certain cases uh in which
perhaps the western governments went too
far but certainly there's been some
cases that uh
the evidence has been pretty
overwhelming that individuals have been
caught uh spying for china so i i think
frankly it's a sensitive issue in
western countries they're trying to
balance respect
and care for their ethnic chinese
compatriots with legitimate concerns
about espionage directed by the chinese
government
and finally subbing i i wanted to get
your take on the place that the pla
holds in the in the chinese mindset the
chinese heart because i feel like the
notion of the deaf and during the
liberation army has been an integral
part of patriotic stories um this idea
that they are for the people uh that
they have noble self-sacrifice you know
stories like leifong this 22 year old
pla soldier who was this modern-day
communist saint for being so
self-sacrificial
taught throughout schools in china do
you think that
people buy that narrative and do you see
the army
off a party of the ruling party not of
the country as we've already talked
about do they see them that army with
that kind of endearment that um those in
beijing would like them to
yeah this is still true to today the
party and the country uh praised
military as the great war as the
uh symbol of the country yes i think
that uh
china continued
uh to promote the poa and pushed poa
as a symbolic or political
machine to
maintain
not only the security safety and also
the unity and the stability of the
country
they believe as long as the army is
stable and trustful
loyal
china
is safe
so military is very important
for the party and for the country
so
uh during the crisis like pandemic
earthquake
or any other disasters uh people and
party
always
turn
to the military for the help
so
but that could be another
way you know when there's a
international crisis or u.s china
relations
and
turn
back
party may use a military
as a
tool
to put the pressure on the u.s
doesn't have to be attack on taiwan it
could be a little conflict over
somewhere in south china sea
so put a little bit more pressure on the
u.s to improve
the relations in terms of trade
technology
and other matters
so military always used
by the party
different way you know that so it could
be used by the party again
as an instrument to improve
their relations
between china and the u.s
by starting something somewhere else
or crisis i i think xiaobing is talking
about like
you know a small crisis i don't think
the chinese want yeah noises or problems
not real military conflict but they had
attention
so
u.s have to talk to me now you know if
not going to be something bad happen
so that's you inventory could be used in
that way i see yeah and in china today
do today's young people
i don't know if you would know this uh
will still want to join the people's
liberation army yeah so there's there's
some evidence you know reporting
provided by the chinese media that
suggests
uh for rural people
joining the pla is still very attractive
unfortunately for those young people
that is not the demographic that the pla
is trying to attract they're trying to
attract educated college people and
those young people are not as interested
in serving in the pla and in fact there
have been reports where uh the chinese
government has had to punish young
people who refused to serve and
disobeyed when they were conscripted
and and uh and so
and the chinese military has lowered
standards for college educated people to
get in
so they're relaxing rules and trying all
kinds of ways to incentivize college
educated urban people to join the pla
but they still are not getting the
numbers they need and that continues to
be an issue for uh the pla
yeah there were there were changes you
know during the after the cultural
revolution during 80s and 2000
for example there is a one-track policy
after 79 so most chinese family
had only one child
of course parents did not want his only
son to serve in the military
so that time military had the problem
with their recruitment
and then during the 2000s because of the
commercialization and globalization
and any job as a the job market became
open
so military wasn't
the best way to get where you want to go
so military lost their
uh
leverage
but they start a new program like what
do i don't know what to call it in the
great britain but in a market called
rotc
the student cadet
program
so the university like beijing
university qinghai university began to
recruit student slash officer
to the university after the graduation
they agreed to serve in the military for
certain years
so through those educational programs
uh proa still keep
trying to get the best
for the service in the recent years
lisa bing and timothy heath thank you so
much for joining chinese whispers
thank you for watching this episode of
chinese whispers if you've just come
across the podcast on youtube you can
find more episodes through searching for
chinese whispers wherever you get your
podcast from there is a brilliant
backlog of episodes not on youtube and
if you have feedback do leave a comment
below preferably constructive and
subscribe to the spectator's youtube
channel so you never miss any of our
spectator tv shows thanks for watching
[Music]
you